I declare we have any ketchup mm-hmm
using ketchup I'm David and I'm Matt hi
I'm joy I'm Blake and today we're taste
testing some beef to figure out which
restaurant is from Wendy's is probably
the best burger if we're not talking
about like Shake Shack in college they
still got a Wendy's a lot because of a
poor floor and I was always poor Carl's
jr. my burger king over Wendy's all day
really all right number one I think the
easiest one yes cuz the shape exactly is
it a way where I like it yeah I will say
that it's thicker than the other one so
you probably have more bang for your
buck here I thought they Susan their
meat a little bit more if you just eat
the meat too straight up and yes often
there's no there's not much going on
flavor-wise oh yeah always I don't know
maybe it's the cheese that yeah ladies
he go any ugly but I think we're
figuring out that the condiments is what
really sends enough number two to the
initial guess to me I think this is a
McDonald's patty yep same yeah is it so
flat now it's gonna get tricky because
they're not square anymore huh yeah I'm
so confused
just like that one nine dollars it's
really thin and I mean look at that
[Laughter]
okay flat it looks like it's got like
bits in it like little seeds or
something like probably some sesame
sesame seeds to complement the bunnies I
mean is some form of it
I believe is the golf crazily it up I
will say that it has a little bit more
flavor than the wind using pet it it is
a good plan yes I'm gonna say that's
Nick dong because it's like saltier and
I was like a different flavor to it
later the seasoning
I think definitely McDonald's yeah I'm
definitely not going to go number three
now this was the one that was very
questionable who is one that I could
have put my mind am i wrap my head
around it does have a little bit of like
yeah yeah but it has a little it feels
crunchy err on the edges like they
cooked it differently see what this
tastes like
it's definitely the driest one yeah
Tyrion so far oh god I'm gonna say Jack
and water this one but this is the least
flavorful one oh yeah I'm not less than
with that no flavor yeah no like real do
we have ketchup is this McDonald's man I
don't know this is just lacking lacking
um maybe it just tastes better with the
sauce and all that but without it if
this is McDonald's there's a problem
hello double-o Andrews murders are way
better just say okay they are last one
now I'm gonna just run with Burger King
on this just cuz of the Charbroil
you know they got the whole thing here's
like his baby daddy over here brother I
have a big burger king in a cool little
minute but that's all the fella really
good yeah that's definitely Burger King
the commercial always has flames in the
grill marks yeah see that one has a lot
of grill marks it's never like real
marks oh yeah boss I'd like just like
put this side down and hope for the best
but a lot of what burning burgers have
like weird meat pops
why don't you slimy bits it's like pods
pods are in here they do have little
bubbles oh yeah what is that
bubbles almost definitely Burger King it
has like the like the flame-broiled
taste or whatever it tastes dramatically
different from all the other one yeah it
does taste like it's been like on a
flame yeah it definitely there's more
barbecue I just want to say we killed
this we got these right okay I'm 100%
calm we got all of them right
I can't do this exam this is definitely
Wendy's me now in Wendy's for sure
square patty yes nailed it oh okay one
now five McDonald's I'm sales McDonald's
that so number two we thought was
McDonald's
McDonagh stay scared you'll be trying to
mess with us
number three this one's jack on the
black side we think this one is the
classic jack-in-the-box
alright alright alright
we just got a 100 on this test and this
number for flame-broiled Too Faced
beauty is from Burger King Gang Gang yes
I'm out here testing burgers for loose
Thank You Crowder same Wendy's has in my
opinion the most seasoned burger it's
all about Wendy's well it's like not
even close
having them next to each other I'm
realizing that Wendy's just kind of has
like it's just all together better than
the other three
I'm glad to go Wendy mm-hmm but this did
make me appreciate those homemade
hamburgers not my parents used to be
fine while the onions coming up beside
and everything like that yes Deborah
we're quick kids are stupid
Thank You buzz why
[Music]